i'm so tired of this nonsense i'm tired
of this
i think this video caused me to get a
copyright
i hate youtube recently oh my god i hate
youtube
like why do you guys do this to me
okay oh actually this video i need to
react to
[Applause]
at the dramatic life experience you know
we are
gloria allred
gloria allred you know what gloria
already said yes so you know sometimes
you know we are sold a philosophy
by somebody who has had dramatic life
experiences that we haven't had right
but they impose their philosophies on to
you and you kind of sit there and say
i'm gonna buy that but you shouldn't buy
that because it may not work for your
life it's extra but because the other
person is such a better salesperson it's
so much emotion into it you buy into it
right you got to be very careful which
philosophies of people you buy so i
remember when i interviewed her gloria
we're in our office i walk in
and you know she
she's a perfect like she's
oh wait no what did i do okay wait
uh i'm gonna do an intro just so i can
clip this okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to rolotomasi
on the illusion of women's independence
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
also i'm raising money for equipment
this stream what equipment i am doing a
live show called the pre-game why
because conversations at the pre-game is
always better than the party i'm gonna
have four girls right now hang out we're
gonna do live show
i wanna make it eight i want to get up
to eight mics um and i need about a
thousand dollars raised i'm at like 250
of that so
send donations i would really appreciate
it okay
you're familiar with gloria allred you
what gloria already said yes so you know
sometimes you know we are sold a
philosophy
by somebody who has had dramatic life
experiences that we haven't had right
but they impose their philosophies onto
you and you kind of sit there and say
i'm gonna buy that but you shouldn't buy
that because it may not work for your
life it's extra but because the other
person is such a better salesperson and
so much emotion into it you buy into it
right you got to be very careful which
philosophies are people you buy so i
remember when i interviewed her gloria
we're in our office i walk in
and you know she
she's a perfect like she's the for
people that know who glory already is
how do you define who she is michael
jordan of
sexual harassment lawsuits right can we
say that yeah an attractive older woman
accomplished by the way i had the most
incredible time sitting down with her
when the interview was done because
things got heated when the interview was
down i said can i hug you
she says you know what patrick all you
have to do is ask that's the cap i'm not
okay so she gave me the biggest hug we
laughed it out but i pushed her she
pushed me i said look gloria you talk
about feminism and women's rights and
all this stuff how many people you got
working here a lot why is it that the
front desk clerk was a woman but all
your partners pictures on well they're
all men well well are you how about you
patrick are you not a bigot it was like
such an interesting dynamic but then i
said i want to find out about this later
lady when i looked at a documentary
looked at study stuff on her when she
was in cancun do you know the story
about what happened to her in cancer
going to mexico so when she was younger
in her early mid 20s very attractive
girl
she goes to a doctor she meets a doctor
dr says let's go back to my practice i
want to show you my office in the office
she she he rapes her okay
and she keeps it to herself for a while
but she creates this
level of anger towards men right
so later on she gets married uh to this
man then they get a divorce i think
after she gets a divorce you know he
ends up committing suicide the guy kills
himself her first husband and the second
husband she gets married they get a
divorce she keeps the last name but sues
the hell out of him and he saw what
happened to her daughter her daughter is
not kind of similar doing what she's
doing i don't know if you're following
the foot she's following her footsteps
similar personality strong personality
and she's out there saying independent
women independent women independent
women independent women and women are
like she's right she's right she's right
and it may work for some but some
actually do want to have a family do
want to have you know do want to have a
husband do want to stay
it's such a hard crossroads
um
[Music]
anyway you know build something together
with them how do you differentiate
between
you know somebody who is selling a bag
of goods that maybe worked for her
because she had a painful experience how
do you process that how do you get
somebody who's listening to this oh my
gosh that is so true
do you guys hear my dog snoring in the
background right now
but
so many women will sell feminism
i mean like strong and independent like
that's gonna
lead to your happiness but it really
doesn't to be honest
it doesn't makes you just like angry
about [ __ ] well she's right
versus saying i don't know if that
philosophy is going to work for me long
term it's it's very difficult to
make a rational argument with people who
are like seated and steeped in
emotionalism and anger is definitely
emotion and resentment and and you know
regret um revulsion there's all kinds of
different emotions that go along with
that so i can be the most rational guy
in the world and say here's the
statistics here's here's the dynamics
here's just the dots that i'm connecting
yeah i'm not going to change that
person's mind if we're if if she's
having an emotional
argument and i'm having a rational
argument because we're talking past each
other um my
most people when they have a
conflict of interest or they have like
oh you you believe in a philosophy and
i'm like no i don't believe in a
philosophy i believe in empirical data
here it is uh the only way they can win
that uh that rational argument is by
converting it into an emotional argument
and that's
you know in a nutshell kind of what
happens when you're trying to oh my gosh
yes
you know what i hate it
i hate when
people
start doing personal experiences
or sob stories like this one sob story
when we're talking about ideas
it irks me okay
because i have
personal experience right
with things that i could use to argue
pretty emotionally
certain laws
but i don't even mention them on live
why
i don't think it's fair
i don't i don't think that's
fair
late uh red pill awareness when you're
trying to it's not the pregame but it's
dope i know
i know it's coming wednesday at eight
i'm gonna make a post about it today
but wednesday eight o'clock
we're going to do the live i already
have uh
two guests i want i'm gonna get
i learned my lesson from last time i'm
gonna invite six people and assume four
will come so to relate the kind of
material that i actually let me check my
messages and see if she said
who else should i invite
did you anyone that watched the testing
pregame who are your favorite guests
um
[Music]
i'm getting really tired i've been
cleaning all day today
um
[Music]
gabby the asian chick and everyone else
okay
the people who are very
ego invested into like their
personalities are dependent on that
belief set so unless they get to a point
of crisis unless they get to a point of
of really kind of desperation or they
have you know through some miracle they
have some sort of insight about things
you're really probably not going to
change their minds about it
the best you can do is to present you
know pick your battles uh ask uh lead
the witness right ask uh pertinent
questions at the time when those when
those
topics arise um but as far as like when
we're talking about like this
cultural narrative
of the power in a strong independent
woman right now it's practically a brand
we've been talking about the strong
independent woman since 1970 since
gloria steinem okay
and
why is that a broken philosophy
it's a broken philosophy for for several
years some people some people well and
that's the thing
they sell women this like bill of goods
that will be so happy if we just pursue
a career
when
everyone i know
that is like 60
and childless i don't know a single
person that's happy with that decision
maybe at 35 maybe at 40 but 60 70
45 independent of what what are women
independent of you guys can hear the
video right
men they're independent of men's
provisioning so when we go back remember
i told you how everything goes back to
the micro the micro level is this for
women women's mating strategy is
hypergamy okay and i mean that on two
fronts it's dual it's not just one like
a lot of people mistake hypergamy as oh
well women marry up it's not just about
that women also are looking for
short-term sexual genetic benefits they
want the hot guy in the foam cannon
party in cancun on spring break you know
they want the hot fireman that arouses
them and gets their blood boiling and
then they want the guy who's also like i
said attraction who is the guy who's a
good long-term security prospect so it's
cats versus dads that's the that's kind
of like the dynamic that women have to
choose they have to find the best fit
between those two things in today's
society really since 1970 we have
developed a a social order that has sold
women you don't need to worry about
long-term security we've got
we've got no fault divorce we've got uh
child support laws we've got uh the
duluth model of feminism we've got um
okay rolo has actually stepped up his
game so much like
i think he has improved so much the last
couple months and just communicating his
message like better because a lot of
times when you first listen to his stuff
i don't think he's very likable
until you listen to a lot of his stuff
and then you realize what he's talking
about but he has like gotten so much
better at conveying his points like
shorter if that makes sense
more women in the workplace i just go on
down the line of how much money does
pearl lack before the pregame show um
i'm going to be able to do it on
wednesday at 8. that's what i'm i'm
gonna post about that's today i'm gonna
make the post
however however um
i wanna get eight mics
and i have four so i need about 700 more
dollars to get to the second set of four
mics
of all the benefits that have that women
have accrued since the time of the
sexual revolution all of those point to
one thing which is long-term security
for women so when we're talking about
like abortion on demand that's a
fail-safe for bad reproductive choices
that is the function of abortion is to
say you know what well i i he's not i
don't he's not a good prospect for the
future but this guy is and so therefore
we
ah
that's very true
very that option just having that option
that is exactly why women will fight
tooth and nail to keep abortion legal
not me oh god
this wave attire just hit me not me
i will not be fighting for that that's
number one you think that's the reason
absolutely also do you guys see my skin
it's clearing up
you guys have seen my acne the last
couple months
look at this clear
almost it's not completely clear it's a
little bit
but it's it's coming i'm i'm excited
put the cash app in the link okay hold
on
cash app is just pearly things
function of it so p women will say well
it's because of uh you know bad decision
really what else is it i mean is it is
it uh uh is it bad philosophy is it bad
religion is it bad whatever so let's
practice what is the
oh
hold on guys
i tried to get my brother a date with
this girl that has a million followers
she saw it but she said she has a
boyfriend
anyways sorry
sorry this is a distracted stream today
what you're saying is if if a girl
hooks up with an nfl player she'll keep
the baby but if she hooks up with a
you know neighbor because one night she
was alone and he came he was a school
teacher regular guy she may abort that
baby but kids
that's what you're saying and that's
exactly why you have no seat at the
table when we start talking about
abortion laws you don't have a uterus
and therefore you don't get to you don't
have a say i think that's wrong
so it's half the man's baby two
you know what nfl train on that by the
way just a side note nfl train that
every time you have sex with a condom uh
uh flush the flesh economy it was nba
nba that yeah
i mean now it's everybody have you seen
what happened recently in the news and
then tabloids with drake yeah the hot
sauce and the condom situation you know
where he got that from was tom lycus
from back in the night
because i did i did a segment on that
and everyone's like tom likes someone
oh yeah dm me questions for the show
wednesday for sure
just dot pearly things that's my
instagram dm me dm me yes tom likes yes
women always say they have a boyfriend
oh did my brother get rejected
my question is like drake why are you
putting cholula sauce in a freaking
condom just flush it down the toilet i
don't know if it wasn't on fire
i believe it was 2001 the nba released a
press release to all their players who
are on road trips because they had such
a high incidence of women that they were
sleeping with while they were on road
games uh essentially uh they would use a
condom and the women would let's say
inseminate themselves with the leftovers
in the condom so that they could have a
kid with an nba player so that is a goal
of many of those it was so common that
they had to make a press release for
that and of course tom like is being the
extreme guy he was you know this is well
you should put tabasco sauce in there so
like when she does that but continue you
were saying continue you were you you
were going to a point there feminism
and that's just one one factor that goes
along and so what we have done is we've
established a social order where men are
unnecessary and we what's the ig just
and then a dot pearly things so it's my
it's my youtube name there's just a dot
after just i mean today we'll say this
we don't need men we're i don't even
know man i don't need no man if this is
the 6'3 brother who appeared on break me
mondays yes he normally does but this
girl with a million followers i guess
was a no but i want a man okay
what man do you want to get with what
man is that it's usually the guy who's
the quote-unquote stereotypical alpha
chad guy hot guy in the foam cannon
party she wants the alpha seed side of
hypergamy not the beta needs side
because at least there's this idea
that that side of security that side of
her mating strategy is going to be
settled and when they get to the point
where they're 33 34 35 years old and
they're asking me rolo where are all the
good guys how come i can't find a guy
who is you know makes more money than me
or is is ready to go forward they're
also okay guys um i'll tell you the vid
the what happened with my brother so he
had he asked me to get him a date with
this tick tocker and i was like adam
she's got like a million followers um
she's not going to respond so i made
this video i'll show you the video
hold up
okay this tick tock is for nicki woods
if you're not nicki woods keep scrolling
hey girl what's up um so
my little brother adam
has a crush on you um and he thinks
because i have a following like somehow
like i can get you to go on a date with
him a little bit about adam he's 6'4
um he's a really hard worker okay he's
you're 19.
is adam 21 is he 22 i don't know close
enough anyways i think it'd be really
funny to like surprise him
with you because you're like his you
know celebrity crush and everything he
doesn't you know really do pictures or
instagram but this is the fam you know
could be you next christmas um it's that
brother right there you know tall
anyways dmv on instagram feel free to
help a girl out you know okay
so and she commented on that video and
said this is so cute
but i have
a boyfriend
sorry what do i respond to that if it's
a [ __ ] test
hmm
um
asking your sister to set up a date
never works
apparently not it didn't so
irresponsible they're all threatened by
powerful strong powerful women and the
only answer i have for them is you have
created yourself into the man that you
wanted to marry
and so when when women hit me up and
they asked me about this and they say
okay well what can i do what can i do to
be uh to to find a long-term a long-term
guy and they're 34 35 years old and
these they get very very frustrated
they're like i'm i guess i'm going to
die alone you know i guess that they've
resigned themselves to to you know
being a spinster listener an old
spinster exactly and so what i say is
well you know what are the men that
you're looking for what are they looking
for in a woman well they're looking for
femininity they're looking for a woman
who's hot they're looking for sexual
availability they're looking for a woman
who can nurture who might be a good
mother in the future i mean there's all
of these sort of conventional
feminine qualities that they don't
embody anymore and so when they say well
what do i got to do i got to play dumb i
got to play the ditzy blonde i've been
told my whole life that i needed to be
in charge and powerful and everything
else and as as
as patrick was saying just a minute ago
is women
want to be or they believe that they
need to be in those positions of power
because they can't depend on a man men
are irresponsible men
[Music]
yeah
and that's how you can always tell a
girl is like
damaged because her mind always goes to
what if they can't do it
no girl wants to feel more competent
than her partner
no one are untrustworthy men like gloria
all read for example uh i i don't need
no man or they have a very uh
misandrous uh attitude towards guys as a
result of life experience or whatever
but it doesn't even have to be something
as dramatic as that it can be simply
like watching disney pixar movies that
do nothing but say you can do anything
you could be an astronaut and have
babies at the same time and you can you
know be in the military do you know one
girl that really did do everything
there's very few but the one that did
nikki freaking hayley
that woman
and that supreme court justice that
the girl that like trump appointed they
both got fam oh my gosh and fight wars
and you can go and be a computer
whatever it is you know the sky's the
limit girl and you have you know three
four generations of women who are raised
on that they believe that they have to
be the one who provides that security
for themselves so as a result you have
careerist women who are getting more
degrees than men we constantly we point
at men when we talk about this but let's
look at the stats here there are more
women who i don't know women wanted
those positions when they were well
taken care of
i mean i think some girls
like i really like working
like i like working hard at something
like i get like an adrenaline rush and i
work hard at something now the rest
starts to go away when i feel like i'm
working hard and getting no payoff which
often feels like this channel
[Music]
but but
yeah so who are enrolled in college
there are more women in doctor programs
there are more women who get master's
degrees um i mean just educationally
speaking we can we can you know parse
that out women are making more money
than than men are these days are
increasingly more anyways um and then
women spend more money that that is part
of the family unit right now with 90 of
of uh american homes the woman is the
one who makes all of the big economic
decisions for those homes so it's not
necessarily earning capacity or this
wage gap kind of thing it's who is
making the spending who's doing the
women make 80 percent of consumer
decisions everything that is produced in
the media is for women
two women about women
okay what do i want to watch next
i'm going to probably do one more and
then go to bed i'm getting kind of tired
or at least
edit some stuff
i'm just not feeling like being on
camera too much longer
oh my gosh hello sandra
i'm thinking guys when i get a bigger
membership
following
i want to do like meetups in different
cities
i mean this is this is a later problem
right this is a but this is just how my
brain works okay
i think it would be cool to have like
fun events
in different cities
so like go to miami and do
i don't know maybe like singles like
meetup events
i don't know
um it's coming together
groceries have also gone up
substantially oh my gosh they have
guys i'm so poor i'm so poor
hi sandra
oh my gosh guys okay i started a meal
plan do you guys see how clear my skin
is getting
it's from this meal plan it's this guy
on twitter
and he
you tell him the foods that you already
like eating
okay
and
you can
um
and he makes like a meal plan for you
and you can like you have to go to like
and what i do is i order the groceries
so i have them all for the week
and it takes you minutes you have to
type in all the groceries individually
that part's annoying but other than that
other than that okay
um
it's like pretty easy and all the foods
i like because i said i was like look
dude i really don't like vegetables i
just don't
and none of the stuff
was veggies and i love it so
what i should do
is i'm going to give you a link to this
guy
if you guys want no pressure
but
i'm down five pounds and my skin is the
biggest thing look at my videos from
like a month or two ago
look it is getting clearer by the day
like that was why i wouldn't wear makeup
for a while was because i hated how it
looked on my skin
um
let me guess no dairy um it's not no
dairy it's like kefir
kefir milk so it's a little different
annie lets me have um yogurt without the
it's a little bit of dairy
wait let me
let me find the link if you guys want it
um
i'm just going to put in the chat
and
and then i have a code you guys get 50
off
and i'm only recommending this because i
bought it and i actually enjoy it um
and i'm not really going to promote it
too much till after i can do like a
before and after video you know
oh maybe i don't i thought i got a code
well anyways for now
if you guys are interested in that i'm
gonna just give you a link
um
no it's not no dairy it's less dairy
but okay look at my fresh infinite video
from like six months ago
where i was like saying i don't i
wouldn't go on their show again whatever
like just pearly things fresh if it'll
come up my skin is a disaster in that
video
a good topic for a video is men's
fertility oh that's interesting i don't
know anything about that
um
but yeah i'm telling you okay it's kind
of expensive like i paid like 250 for
this thing
but i promise you this is the i have
done so many fitness things
so many i'm like the queen of diets i've
been trying to lose and i don't even
want to
promote it too much until i've actually
you know done it for a couple months and
that way i can like show you guys the
results and all that i'm gonna do a full
video
um
but
but
my skin is already clearing up and it's
only been like a week and a half and i'm
down five pounds
so and i don't feel like hungry all the
time that's the biggest thing
is i would always feel like these
horrible
horrible like like hunger
like i don't describe it like this pit
in my stomach i could not feel full
and this has made me feel so much better
so anyways
i really recommend it sorry i've been
talking about this for a while
um
i wanted to watch this video
some guys have a fetish for a pizza face
okay well i don't want to date those
guys
i want the guys that like clear skin
girls because
look you see this you see this oh my
gosh it's so much better you don't even
understand
utu what a d it's your boy steph welcome
back to another code video man we dive
into a cold video topic man before we do
that
girl i'm about to pay to get the fat off
my hips okay girl look at listen to me
listen to me
i also
was thinking
i've thought about botox i've thought
about all that stuff but you know what i
told myself i said i will not do any of
that stuff until i do
every single thing i can
non
you know surgically
to get this [ __ ] off and to get this
clear and to like
do all that i will fix everything and
then i will spend money if it's that bad
anyways sorry i'm going to continue you
guys follow me on instagram
it's code
and make sure you guys follow all my
socials link is in the description
follow my twitch and join the discord
man so now we're going to dive into this
video topic man last night i'm on the
phone with my guy man we talking
business and stuff and at the same time
i'm working at my desk and you know i
have a i have a tv right there i got uh
my gaming uh tv here my monitor right
there and i have my pc right here my
macbook right here
and i have to watch tv right there i'm
watching i'm watching the next game last
night
and we know
ben simmons just got traded right
as i'm watching the next game
i'm watching seth curry hit the three
they call the timeout next is getting
the momentum here come ben simmons
walking
so as ben simmons walks we're gonna
watch this video
check it out watch this we're gonna
watch this video together let's let's
watch it
look look y'all
look y'all
look y'all hold on look
look we let me see this right look
look out look at how this chick
give him the triple look right in front
of her [ __ ]
[ __ ] no respect for her [ __ ] [ __ ] no
respect for her [ __ ] she don't care
wait where wait i didn't see it
where is she i missed it oh okay one
time
two times
three times
you see the one time she looked at him
i didn't think that was that big of a
deal oh my gosh
you see the you see the look she's
giving her
she can't help she she can't help me so
much her her god i mean look at people
look at attractive people i do the same
thing with girls i don't think that's
that big of a deal some people are so
good looking it is distracting
right there next to her
she looking at him sitting down
she can't help
utmost disrespect right in front of her
man
she did she did
she
[Applause]
[Music]
gonna break her [ __ ] neck [ __ ] she
can't help it
can't help it can't control her emotions
she a seven foot giant
coming out the blue
what's another thing we noticed in the
video what's another thing we noticed in
this video right
thing we notice is
she ain't turning her head she's looking
with her eyes
she's looking with her eye yeah this is
just reaching a little bit
look it people look at attractive people
it doesn't have to be this deep stuff it
really doesn't okay
if a dude looks at a girl with a fat ass
this is the common sense
am i am i going to be mad i'm not going
to appreciate it
i'm not going to enjoy it
but like
for a second oh my gosh y'all overthink
[ __ ]
she's doing this
can't help it bro
and dude know
you know what i'm saying he know that's
why he looked at ben like okay he
already know what time it is
this is a and this is what i'll be
telling y'all bro the dating game is red
dawg simply because bro
a nba player could be simply because bro
my girl looked at an nba player let's be
like my boyfriend looked at a model oh
no
our cheek dms at any given moment bro
and it's going to give her all the
validation and attention that she wants
oh my god
okay as someone who's had nba players
respond to me in my dms i promise you i
do not think that i'm getting wiped up
by an nba player any time soon
okay i'm just gonna i'm gonna just i've
had guys respond to me from the nba you
saw the video i did a video on it
but am i am i going to be an nba wife no
he's watching this clip together bro
we're watching this clip
seeing what's happening
oh my god okay i need that this man is
crazy
um
can you tell i've been watching true
crime today
hmm hold on hold on
get pearl a date guys stop it i'm like i
have so many dates
i'm like
i'm like so
dateful i
i have so many guys just lined up to
date me it's like crazy i
i can't even count them there's just
like so many
stop
don't make this a hashtag
stop it i have so much game like my game
is unparalleled
like my game is ridiculous
[Laughter]
looks so i'm not lonely at all
[Music]
i'm like
i'm not even a little bit lonely
i'm just kidding
um
okay actually i want to see rolo
oh wait let me check on my laundry
i know i think it's still going
you have three sixes hit your line my
instagram is just dot pearly things
okay
all right
but i'm super like
there's just so many people
dying
[Laughter]
dying to date me
um
it's like a win a date with tad
never trust a woman's public tears
um
look it okay guys
you're gonna have to fight off all
the guys just dying
dying to be my my boo thing
my booth y'all
okay i'm done i'm done i'm done i'm done
i'm done
with each other for a handful of years i
was in the bin of the party scene
there's models there's guys there's rich
guys you know the whole thing and i
remember this one time i i came up with
this question and now i ask it all the
time and i want to get your guys
thoughts on it would you rather
be with i mean be relationship be with a
guy
very wealthy you're taken care of i mean
you're driving what you want to drive
you're living where you want to live
you're shopping where you want to shop
you're living your life but he's kind of
a little bit maybe older a little
sloppier not exactly in good shape he's
not ex you're not exactly
attracted to him but you're attracted to
lifestyle that's option a option b
hot dude sexy ripped you know good sex
funny cool you know all that
broke as [ __ ] lives in his mom's
basement those are your two options
i wish it wasn't all or nothing okay
i really wish it wasn't all or nothing
um
the broke guy i couldn't
i couldn't do it but it's for a
different reason a guy that just does
nothing drives me nuts
is he broke because like why is he broke
why does he live in his mom's basement
if he's like trying to in a field that
just like
doesn't make a lot of money that's one
thing but if he's just lazy like a bum
no girl wants to watch their man do
nothing
i promise you it got me though like i
was i was maybe sold on guy number two
but the basement
i'm just saying he lives oh my god but
if you did like a guy making forty five
thousand dollars a year and hot okay
or a guy making a hundred thousand
dollars a year and ugly
but how ugly that's the question
is he just like a little ugly like kind
of ugly
or
these are the follow-up questions that
have but i think i'm gonna ask this
question on my podcast anyways because
it's a really good question basement or
whatever that might be theoretically
he's broke he's broken he lives he's not
he don't got no money ain't taking you
out he lives
but those are your options
wealthy
but busted
yeah you know broken hot who are you
picking queen victoria i feel like when
i first met you i probably would have
picked guy number one because i was
still experiencing those things um
but now
i would probably go with this guy two
you're twenty you would pick this i'm 29
29
well anyway you you you're saying that
you would pick i knew him when i was
like 20 so i feel like yeah 21 21 for
the record 21.
the nightlife right no
women
women want the best of both options the
sexual appeal the v chapter chiseled
jawline also rich loves puppies and his
mom
i mean yeah if i could choose from
anyone
but do i think that's real oh my
goodness
you guys realize there are some girls
that realize that there are leagues in
men
like just like you guys if you could
have a wholesome model
like a virgin model
you wouldn't you wouldn't pick her if
you could
like get out of here
um
but it's not like black and white
i women we're i'm attracted to work
ethic and it's not about money if a guy
won the lottery i would not be attracted
to him it's about being competent work
ethic like useful
like
that that's what we're attracted to
anyways
you're 21 in south beach you're more
attracted to those
quote unquote glitz and glam and then
now you can kind of see through the
smoke and mirrors and like you're true
you wouldn't be truly happy so who would
you be with long term
the hot guy the hot guy but
like he ain't taking it i would give him
some business advice and he would start
some businesses together okay so you're
going to try to have him level up
she would want to take a
chance on a guy with potential so if the
guy's hot and he kind of has potential
to actually make some money later on
then that's a better bet than the guy
who is not that good looking but has a
lot of money and therefore it becomes
sort of this economic situation when it
goes to to the uh women marry a
lifestyle they don't marry a guy
i've definitely seen that i've seen that
a lot but um
i don't know i think like you have
choices so i wouldn't choose that
rebecca number one who would you choose
of that scenario the the
the wealthy you know not so good looking
guy or the
uh broke hot dude and then what was your
counter argument uh what willow had to
say who's your pick first
i just can't get into your choices you
have to she stays you don't have to so
you're just going to stay single is what
you're saying you'd rather say
i don't know if anybody changes i think
that is a foolish thing do i do i've had
those offers yeah my god if i didn't
have some type of i have this
i have to work i have this mission i
have i have my work to do in the world
i've had that offer all the time of
also yes
send a donation for hot girls on the
pregame um my friends are going to be
coming on help me put the
camera down
so i can okay
my friends are going to be coming on
live monday
wait wednesday at 8. i haven't posted it
yet you're the first to know
like you do not want to know more about
cars than your boyfriend
oh my god yeah
that's very true
like we just want guys that are that are
smart
and useful that's what we're attracted
to usefulness
they're done with their money all they
want to do is enjoy their life
so there's no room for me to grow
i'm not into it i've had
many offers what kind of offers what do
these offers look like
i thought you're gonna take out your
phone
let me show you it's like let me let me
queue it up in my mind i've had straight
up marriage relationship we don't have
to get married you can have your own
place you can live here
uh there was one i've actually been
offered that as well yeah it's guys are
weird yeah
they'll take care of you
i've been offered an apartment from a
guy
um i could have lived off of my last
boyfriend if i wanted to
one guy
offered me an apartment and a new
wardrobe i turned that guy down
you'd be shocked yeah you'd be shocked
but
they'll buy me a house next door the
rest of like no like
the next generation with their wallet
but like i would rather take that guy
was weird the one that offered me the
apartment i'd rather take a guy that's
just like normal and makes 45k totally
then there was somebody else he's like
we would make beautiful babies
that sort of just seemed like babies and
it's like he said you'd have you know if
you have access to this for like forever
no i just it's like manipulative no i
just do that just like we were talking
about the gifts just doesn't do it for
me so i i hear these conversations
this is not my reality this is so not my
world and i know other people like uh
but i mean just so so to your example no
i'm single
so you'd say i'm i'm i'm now
yeah but how long are you going to stay
single for that was the question meaning
until mr wright comes along and who's
perfect he's got the money independent
woman adam i don't need somebody who's
got money i i don't know if this escapes
i mean i'm a phd i'm an author i'm a phd
oh she says i don't know if this escaped
yeah i'm not i'm not like i didn't show
up off the street okay i'm looking for
somebody to take care of not asking i'm
sorry that woman is still attractive
enough that like
she could still get a guy
you guys don't admit it but she could
but i know you probably have very strong
feelings on on on what she's saying
she's she's career women where do you
stand on career women i mean you're more
focused on their statistic right now is
what she is how old are you
uh oh
rolo going in
okay well let's just say for sake of
argument you're in your early 30s okay
maybe you're a little older who knows
um
when women get to that age and they are
career women when they are strong
independent women uh and have spent the
better part of their lives uh building
themselves up to be and have a doctorate
um to um
to uh have their own business your pr
presume you have your own practice
um and are very your your personality
and your ego investments are built up
into what your achievements are and you
get to a certain stage oh that's not me
with the ego investments okay well you
get to a certain stage where it's like
i'm looking for a guy who is like why is
it do you think you're still saying she
wants to find someone that she enjoys
doing activities with and things like
that i haven't found the right fit
exactly and i'm not i'm not trying are
you looking for a guy that is like are
you looking for a guy that makes as much
money as you has the same kind of
achievement as you has the same kind of
education as you what i this is a great
question what i've noticed i've dated a
lot and so i've tried many different
things
the
you can have somebody who's incredibly
wealthy
and is awful at conversation just like
makes me want to kill myself then there
are other people have very different
things that they offer
so somebody who is maybe
not as well established maybe very
interesting then there are people who
have you know different kinds of jobs
right so i've tried i've tried dating a
lot of different people
what i find is i need the mind i really
need the mind the rest of it is sexual
it's just
it just i
i always assume you're like a little bit
crazy if you say sapiosexual i'm sorry
meet somebody who's incredibly smart
i just need that
and i need somebody also who is
ambitious and really has in goal like
because there are very nice people
and they're fine to work and this is
wonderful it works really well for other
people
she's hot bit easy to see she's
accumulated a lot of male dna across her
lifetime
probably but
yeah probably
but i don't know why you guys could tell
me if this is just a vibe
but i've noticed is like people that are
older like
35 30 plus
they don't really care that much
about body count it's almost like they
just like stop caring because at that
point everyone's
kind of
like
every
guy that i've dated that's like older
has never asked never even cared
i'm not
and i know you guys would say oh he
wasn't trying to date you seriously
[Music]
no he was he was
um
but you know the people will argue with
you say whatever but but
yeah i don't know why it just seems like
the older like people get the less they
care about that stuff settle down i'm
not looking for any of that i have work
to do in my life so hold on stop you
don't want to have kids god no what do
you mean god no you don't want to have
kids i never have okay why is that
they're terrible kids are terrible
aaron clary this girl right here
i feel like do you want to have kids
i've always wanted to be a mother i
think it's my life purpose but um
like today's world your life's purpose
is to have kids to be a mom okay like i
think
yeah like i always wanted to be a mom
and then um
would you rather be a mom or a career
woman
i think today you could do both
i get it i could also i could eat pizza
and work out i get it but like you got
to pick one though if i had to pick one
then a mom yeah of course you'd be a mom
but you would have you've obviously
picked your career that would be my hell
i mean like
i'm so happy for you what happened that
that you were like that's it
i'm never having kids she's like badass
woman what do you mean clearly she's a
badass you notice how she's like
protecting her victoria she's beautiful
but
but you're very anti kids like like
usually there's women
that will say look you know i'm open to
it if the right guy comes along yeah you
know but like you're very like steadfast
no hell no i got mission i got work to
do no kids first thing first when i get
to when somebody even wants to approach
me i was like i'm if you're looking for
a wife and children i'm not your guy you
have to be a girl
i want no part of this so like don't
don't come around so i've had people who
they'll date me for a while and then
they'll think they'll think that i think
they can change
i actually like that you're like
committed though and know that i've had
a couple girlfriends that are similar
and like know they don't want kids
um
so like i actually really respect that
thank you how come you let me ask you
why are you single right now why do you
think you're single right now because
there's nobody i want to be with right
now
is that they're just not forthcoming or
are you just not me she's waiting for us
after valentine's day
i meet i meet men
all of the time i know what i like and
when it comes around
what's the longest relationship you've
had um
four years i usually like so
i have them like three years four years
two years like that see my my my read on
you is that you are the man you want to
date you you turn yourself in oh no you
see her
expression
oh my gosh
to the guy that you want to date and
most women who like are like sort of the
boss babes or the alpha females what
happens is they live these lives where
they have to go i mean we when you look
at uh what college college debt right
now college enrollment when you look at
business when you look at the fact that
women are complaining about guys not
being economically attractive right now
and when you look at that like i was
quoting these stats to uh to um patrick
on on the other show is you know men
have to make 58 more than the woman is
making to be economically attractive
also from the women's perspective
um
i know a woman all the way up to her
late 20s she never wanted to get married
and have children she's a great career
she's married with three kids now you
know guys don't
i want to choose my words carefully but
from what i've seen guys don't want to
date a non-educated uh goalless woman so
we actually too have to like be our best
version to it
this isn't a fun reality for us driven
women out there
men don't really care they want a
supportive woman
okay i'm sorry this is this is my
this is my thoughts on this okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna make this full
screen okay
oh no that's my school stuff okay
oh i'm frozen on that one well that's
okay this one's fine
i've seen men wife up hoes i've seen men
wife up women that are overweight i have
seen men and the quality men i'm not
saying they're like you know
high value but good guys
good guys
wife up hoes wipe up overweight women
wife up
ton of different stuff like that okay
if they are supportive
men want to feel supportive supported
men will look up over so much stuff okay
for a girl that is just like really
really supportive of you
so
anyways that's that's my closing thought
is
and nice like you guys just like they
don't care about your goals they don't
really care what you're doing they think
it's like you know cool you got
something going on but it's not
you know
in general right there's exceptions to
every rule all right
anyways
they are naive
[Music]
no they're not
they're really not
a girl can get away you guys you guys
could
say what you want in the manners to hear
but women have all the power in the
dating market today
a guy finds a girl that's just like down
for him
super supportive
kind
a lot of guys will just be like whatever
i do not care
i'm not saying this is a fun reality i'm
not i'm not even saying like this is how
it should be
this is just what i've seen and what
i've seen
is that over a certain age men just want
someone nice that supports them and
that's all in for them
and they'll overlook a lot
a lot
so
um
and also
i even talked to my brother about this
adam he's like i just
like
he was saying how
he's like the hoes of your generation
are so much different than the hoes of
my generation like all these girls who
slept with like our ho your host maybe
slept with 20 30 guys our hoes slept
with 50 to 100 and i'm like damn
so
do it that what you might must
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
send donations to just pearly things
okay
for the i saw this comment i'm not
actually going to read this comment
before i before i go bothered me okay
this is more not to come off bad but you
should focus more on being creative
getting more views and solid audience
versus getting focusing on raising
donations as content
unless you have to make the best content
you can and make an income based on that
all right guys
i'm raising money for the equipment
to do a live show you guys get it my
real followers that have been following
me understand what i'm doing here i
don't got to explain it so
but
yeah if you send money for donations
then
or if you send money for the microphones
then hopefully i can host eight people
in here as